[Musique]
je suis désolé he en plus je déteste
qu'on fait ça bonjour Monon bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être notre invité
directeur de l'ONG Singa qui a pour
objectif l'intégration des personnes
réfugiées et migrantes vous êtes ancien
ministre ancien candidat à la
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour ran bonjour benoî Mon bonjour
benoî Mon on va évidemment parler de la
loi immigration mais on avait envie de
vous entendre en tant qu'ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale sur les mesures
qui ont été annoncées hier par Gabriel
Atal et sur cette enquête PISA Gabriel
Atal qui a annoncé un plan choc des
savoirs pour remonter le niveau de
l'école très faible en français et en
mas c'est ce qu'a montré l'enquête PISA
de l'OCDE hier alors Gabriel Atal parle
de refondre des programmes de remonter
du niveau de groupe de niveau de brevet
qui doit être la porte d'entrée du
collège est-ce que ces mesures vont
créer l'électrochoc dont il
parle bon moi je me méfie des éléments
de langage choc des savoirs et des
formules vraiment et je pense que
d'ailleurs à l'éducation nationale il
faut éviter cela parce que l'éducation
nationale c'est le temps long et
personne ne peut penser que un plan
construit de cette manière-là va régler
ce qui pour le coup est la réalité du
système scolaire français le choc des
inégalités qui frapp fracturent
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale
l'école et depuis longtemps et les
respons abilités sont sont partagées
donc c'est la première remarque que je
voulais faire c'est difficile de se
pencher comme ça en quelques minutes sur
le le le le programme de de Gabriel Atal
mais ce que je comprends de ce qu'il va
faire mes frères déterminer et décideré
que dès la 6e on va faire des groupes de
niveau en mathématiques et en français
c'est décrété dès la 6e qu'il va y avoir
les élèves à la cave les élèves au
rez-de-chaussée et les élèves au premier
étage et et c'est s'assuré dans ces
cas-là que ceux qui vont être désignés
pour aller à la cave dès la 6e ils
resteront jusqu'au bout et on sait
parfaitement et et les sciences
éducatives l'ont montré les sciences
sociales également qu'à partir du moment
où on crée des groupes de niveau de
cette manière-là très tôt pour le groupe
qui se situe en bas de la hiérarchie
pour celui-là dans un système qui est
déjà ultra élitiste pour celui-là les
inégalités s'aggraveront et ce que je
crains et ce que je vois d'ailleurs à
travers ce ce ce programme c'est la
réalisation du d'un fantasme des milieux
les plus aisés aujourd'hui et je crois
que c'est difficile d'échapper à son
milieu et et l'intérêt de la politique
je le dis à gabrielal c'est justement de
s'arracher aux représentations aux
imaginaires du milieu auquel on
appartient d'un mot justement et cet
imaginaire des des des des groupes les
plus aisés en France c'est de penser que
ce sont les élèves les plus en
difficulté les élèves issus des milieux
populaires qui tirent tout le monde vers
le bas et on se retrouve avec une
proposition qui va finalement réaliser
ce fantasme des des des milieux les plus
aisés j'ajoute milieux les plus aisés
qui scolarisent la plupart du temps
leurs enfants dans le secteur privé pas
dans le secteur public et et et et je je
crois que tourne le dos à la mission
fondamentale de l'Éc toute une partie
des classes moyennes qui envoient leur
leur pardon leurs enfants vers le privé
est-ce que la vraie inégalité elle est
pas
là une fuite des des élèves de classe
moyenne vers le
privé est-ce que c'est pas une réponse
aux parents justement peut-être alors la
question c'est est-ce que c'est
ah oui mais c'est pas pareil est-ce
qu'on fait quand on est ministre de
dédication on est là pour rassurer les
parents dans le but d'obtenir leur voix
3 ans plus tardce tenir que leurs
enfants reviennent vers le public ouis
j'ai pas l'impression que j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit la pente du du
du ministre de l'Éducation je pense que
si l'enjeu c'était lutter contre les
inégalités la question de la mixité
sociale dans les écoles privées devrait
être posée la question qui est là aussi
l'enquête PISA elle est très
intéressante sur un point elle dit quoi
et c'est c'est les proviseurs qui la
renseignent il a dit que les élèves
interrogés dans l'quête PISA C de cette
cohorte là dans 67 % de leurs
établissements il manquaient des
professeurs pour assurer un enseignement
correct il n'était que 18 % des
proviseurs à le dire en 2018 ça veut
donc dire que les conditions
d'enseignement se sont globalement
dégradé que les classes sont surchargées
et qu'on on répond à cela en disant quoi
et bien on va acter le fait que le
système éducatif français qui est très
inégalitaire très élitiste va
fracturer
finalement des générations dès l'entrée
en 6e en groupe de niveau oui mais alors
lui il dit déjà un qu'on peut sortir de
ces groupes de niveau qu'on peut évoluer
dans l'année d'un groupe à un autre en
fonction de ces compétences et que deux
les élèves qui sont dans les groupes les
plus des élèves en difficultés il y aura
des créations de postes pour qu'il ne
soi pas plus d'une quinzaine par groupe
puisse pour faciliter leur apprentissage
est-ce que c'est pas estce que vous vous
rendez compte la mission de l'école
c'est élever et émancip élev et émancip
là on va dire dès la 6e notamment dans
les milieux les plus défavorisés vous
êtes en bas et s'il voulait permettre la
circulation d'un groupe à un autre il
créerait ce qu'on appelle des groupes
temporaires selon les besoins c'est pas
nous selon les matières mais selon les
besoins flexibl avec des circulation
pourquoi pas il favoriserait le travail
en groupe ce qu'on fait encore mal
aujourd'hui à l'école et au collège mais
là dans les faits on va mais
concrètement donner à voir une
segmentation de la société à l'intérieur
d'une même classe en groupe de niveau et
avec une hiérarchie sociale qui est déjà
quasi immuable où les fils d'employés
deviendront employés eux-mêmes les
filles de cadres viendront CADR
elles-mêmes c'est cette euh euh reprodu
plus l'école aujourd'hui c'est plus
c'est plus un ascenseur social
aujourd'hui mais parce que mais mais
mais il y a
indiscutablement une promesse qui est
celle de l'école qu'elle ne tient pas en
matière de lutte contre les inégalité
c'est c'est l'échec de de de de de notre
école hein depuis maintenant plusieurs
années sinon euh décennies et et sur
laquelle tout le monde se
penche le fait est que j'ai le sentiment
que Gabriel Attal prend acte qu'il faut
un système élitiste il ne lutte pas
contre cela mais il le F est prend aussi
pas Act est-ce qu'il prend aussi pas Act
des résultats des élèves notamment des
difficultés de lecture des difficultés
en mathématiqu quand les résultats
montrent que la moitié des élèves de 4e
ne savent pas lire correctement est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas changer les chos mais
je dis pas je dis pas qu'il faut pas
qu'il faut rien changer c'est pas ça le
sujet la question c'est est-ce qu'on
fige est-ce que aujourd'hui on D on on
envoie comme message dès la 6e à des
enfants vous êtes à la cave et et pardon
de le dire en terme de confiance en soi
et d'estime de soi vous voyez comment
fonctionne un collège un établissement
scolaire vous voyez comment quelle est
comment quels sont les regards et
quelles sont les images qu'on associe à
l'appartenance à tel groupe de niveau
mais mais c'est c'est c'est ça va être
d'une cruauté terrible pour les élèves
qui vont être dans ces niveaux-là dès la
6e et et je le dis c'est c'est euh on le
sait en plus c'est pas comme si on
savait pas ce qui allait se passer la la
les S éducatif nous montre que ce type
de système là aggrave les inégalités
pour ceux qui sont en bas s'il est
demandé au professeur d'accorder plus
d'attention justement au groupe de
niveau le plus bas est-ce que finalement
c'est pas leur donneré une chance
d'accéder aux autres groupes oui mais
bon les professeurs parlons-en ils sont
à peine un quart qu' on signé le PACT
leurs effectifs n'augmentent pas le
budget 2024 n'est pas
satisfaisant on a les classes les plus
surchargées oui mais mais honnêtement
faut faut je je je suis bien placé pour
le savoir on devrait avoir les moyens
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que dans
les écoles collèges et lycées publics on
on nenseigne pas devant des classes de
plus de 30 c'est pas possible si on veut
expliquer mais si on
exp oui bah on revalorise on met les
moyens et et là la vérité c'est que les
choix fait vous reconnaissez que c'est
ce qu' fait Mac de revaloriser le SAL
des moi je considère que les choix qui
sont faits sont très en de ça ça des
besoins qui qui sont ceux de la nation
et de ce qui doit être le contrat entre
l'école et la nation et et et et allez
pas chercher 1000 explications aussi au
fait que ça décroche en France il y a un
moment où ça décroche dans les
classements PISA don par ailleurs il
faut aussi prendre ses distances par
rapport à ce type de classement mais
mais dans les fait quand on a des
conditions d'enseignement qui sont
celles-là euh et ben des facto on peut
pas s'attendre non c'est pas on peut pas
s'attendre à à faire des bons dans les
classements voilà on va parler de la loi
immigration avec plaisir vous étiez très
dur avec la version du texte qui a été
voté par le Sénat aberration politique
et juridique selon vous la version a
était en grande partie détricotée par
les députés en commission tout du moins
est-ce que vous êtes soulagé bon je je
je suis très embêté par rapport à ce
texte je je pense que ça se finira mal
euh c'est ça ve dire quoi se finir mal
parce que ce sera un très mauvais texte
c'est quand même on le dit mais que
beaucoup de ce sans doute qui vous
regardent sont pas d'accord avec les
options que je propose mais c'est quand
même le 30e texte en 40 ans donc allons
pas me raconter que des textes qui
racontent à peu près la même chose si ça
échoue c'est que la la voie proposée est
pas la bonne quelle est la voie elle
postule que aujourd'hui on peut arrêter
lesmigration je veux dire ça simplement
c'est que depuis 30 ans dans le monde
entier les migrations internationales
elles ont augmenté de 60 % c'est
important et moi je ne suis pas de ceux
qui ni que les migrations
internationales augmentent il y a des
raisons à cela on va pas y revenir les
les États ont construit ça c'est les ONG
qui l'ont montré 40000 km de mur
physique du plus des murs juridiques
réglementaires ça n'a absolument rien
stoppé le fait de stopper la migration
légale c'est-à-dire la possibilité de de
de de de d'inclure des personnes
augmente la migration illégale avec un
coût social considérable donc ça c'est
la première donnée ce texte ne changera
rien et et et sachez que vous élirez si
vous faisiez le choix de l'extrême
droite avec un un programme
antimigration le brexit a été voté pour
stopper l'immigration elles ont doublé
depuis brexit en Angleterre c'est les
les l'office statistique britannique qui
le dit M mélonie en Italie a doublé
aussi l'immigration donc bardellaa Le
Pen tout ça ça c'est inefficace oubliez
les politiques publiques dans ce
domaineel ça ne marchera pas donc la
question est de savoir où mett-ons notre
énergie et moi ce que je regrette je
dire quand le ministre en charge de
l'inclusion des personnes étrangères qui
est Monsieur darmana dira-t-il par
exemple que chaque année alors que les
étrangers en France c'est 7,8 % de la
population ils sont 15 % des
entrepreneurs 15 % des créations
d'entreprise ce sont des étrangers quand
dira-t-il qu'un tiers de ceux qui nous
rejoignent ont le niveau licence qui a
un potentiel une capacité à
pouvoir créer des activités créer des
liens enrichir notre société qui est
indiscutable est-ce que c'est pas ce qui
est dit dans l'article 3 justement de
dire on on a besoin de ces talent et
dans lesra oui je comprends que vous
disiez ça il y aurait une petite chose
dans les métiers entention on sait même
pas si c'est 1000 2000 10000 personnes
qui seront régularisé et dernier exemple
je veux juste le dire à vos à vos
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices
qu'on réfléchisse et qu'on fasse le lien
entre immigration et notre système de
retraite notre système de retraite on a
été 90 % des actifs à dire on veut pas
repousser l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
les travailleurs étrangers quand on
regarde cotisent toute leur vie ils ont
des pensions plus faibles en moyenne que
les Français et sur des espérances de
vie plus court donc il rapportent à nos
systèmes de retraite plus qu'il ne coûte
s'il n'y a pas les cotisations des
travailleurs étrangers et demandez-le à
Madame j' dire Madame Bardella Monsieur
bardellaa et Madame Le Pen à quel âge
légal reporteront-ils la date de départ
à la retraite pour les Français 67 68 69
ans pour équilibrer le système c'est ça
que je veux dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
passe sous silence le fait que la
migration est une solution et et et et
c'est pour ça que ce texte alors où où
tranquillement les républicains se sont
rallés au principe de de la préférence
nationale avec cette suppression du
bénéfice des allocations familiales pour
les travailleurs étrangers réguliers qui
cotisent on leur dit vous cotisez mais
il y a pas de contreparti c'est quand
même incroyable c'est pour ça que c'est
juridiquement totalement abérant parce
que c'est inconstitutionnel mais oui
mais alors vous vous défendez la la
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
étrangers sur le territoire est-ce que
c'est pas une prime donnée à ceux qui
rentre de manière illégale c'est ce que
disent notamment les républicains mais
quand vous travaillez vous rendez un
service vous cotisez il y a bien un
employeur qui vous vous êt rentré de
manière irrégulière je je le constate
mais pourquoi parce qu'on a à partir du
moment où on a décidé de de mais de
manière cynique vous croyez Monsieur
Darmanin ou ou tous les autres ne savent
pas que là où vous stoppez la migration
légale vous augmentez la migration
illégale
mais mais évidemment tout le monde le
sait ce que je vous dis tout le monde le
sait et et la réalité c'est qu' en
faisant ça on précarise les gens dans
des proportions incroyables et on en
arrive à ce que même le gouvernement qui
qui qui parce qu'il
est dans les œillères de il faut
expulser il faut comment dire montrer
des signes de fermeté à l'opinion
publique sur les migration on arrive à
faire quelque chose qui qui était au
Sénat à mon avis spectaculaire quand le
ministre de l'Intérieur a dit sagesse
c'est-à-dire a laissé les sénateurs
voter sur la question de la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'État il dit quoi al
c'est pas suppression c'est
transformation en aide médicale
d'urgence c'est-à-dire une restriction
du panier de soin on est d'accord on on
réduit le panier de soin on dit les
étrangers pourront être soignés que
quand ils sont très gravement malade
pour faire vite et c'estàdire que oui là
c'est faire vite parce qu'il y a aussi
la vaccination il y a aussi les
grossesses il y a aussi certaines
pathologies alors je je le dis so à la
foi de ce que disent les médecins et ce
qui est quand même je le note que on a
eu un gouvernement qui nous a dit au
moment de la crise du covid nous allons
sur une question de santé publique agir
selon l'AVE du conseil scientifique
c'est-à-dire des médecins là en l'espèce
on est sur une affaire de santé publique
est-ce que précariser la santé des
travers son papier ne risque pas de
précariser la santé de tous les Français
les médecins disent 3000 d'entre eux les
les les les les plus grandes autorités
médicales disent oui ça va avoir des
conséquences en terme de santé publique
pour tous les Français mais là on
nécoute plus les médecins je je le note
c'estàdire que la vie des médecins il
compte un jour mais il compte pas le
lendemain donc faut être sérieux faut
être sérieux sur l'aide médicale d'État
le sujet il vient de faire l'objet d'un
rapport monsieur claud evvin et
stéphanini qui disent en tout cas qu'il
faut la maintenir il propose quelques
restrictions mais il faut la maintenir
et ne pas basculer vers l'aide médicale
d'urgence je le redis je veux dire qu ou
mais ils disent quand même qu'il faut
resserrer les contrôles qu'il faut
restreindre les bénéficiaires qu'il faut
limiter la liste des pathologies oui
mais là encore moi je suis pas d'accord
je je veux dire c'est quand même assez
étonnant le la jouissance que l'on tire
à faire mal aux autres quand même hein
c'est que on est content et on tire une
sorte de de bonheur collectif à imaginer
que les gens sont aussi est-ce qu'il y a
pas aussi une question d'acceptabilité
sociale vous entendez les Français sur
cette question de laame à dire ben nous
on paye nous on cotise et on a les mêmes
soins ou même pas les mêmes soins que
que ceux qui ne payent pas non c'est ça
ce qui est pas vrai parce que il faut
qu'on arrête cette légende d'abord un la
contribution des travailleurs étrangers
et des étrangers au systèmes sociaux
c'est contribution qui nous permet de
mieux nous soigner nous donc ça c'est
c'est totalement faux on peut prendre on
peut isoler laame mais la réalité c'est
l'OCDE qui le montre c'est que
l'immigration qu'il s'agisse des
cotisations sociales ou des impôts
rapporte plus aux caisses de l'État et
des mécanismes de solidarité qu'elle ne
coûte ça c'est dit répété et et là
encore moi je l'entends pas j'aimerais
que le ministre de l'intérieur quand
venant des bandes droite et extrême
droite on dit ce genre de sautise que le
gouvernement garant de l'intérêt général
dise cela n'est pas vrai on ne peut pas
laisser entendre cela et et et c'est et
c'est là où où c'est insupportable parce
qu'à partir du moment où on on gouverne
et on légifère sur des fantasmes et pas
des faits et bien on ouvre la porte à à
tous les excès et et et et je trouve que
cette loi telle qu'elle se prépare est
une loi qui non seulement sera
inefficace mais mais donne kitus à
l'extrême droite sur un certain nombre
de ses représentations et de ses et du
cauchemar qu'elle représente qui me
préoccupe elle donne quitus ou elle
essaie de L limité parce que ce que dit
général dermanin c'est en effet on le
voit à travers les sondages les Français
sont inquiets de ces vagues
d'immigration et vous le disiez qui qui
qui vont continuer à augmenter on répond
à cette inquiétude en donnant certains
signaux de manière à limité onever aux
élections européennes si c'est efficace
déjà on verra s'il a réussi à à à
cantonner l'extrême droite à un score
inférieur à la liste de de renaissance
puis la deuxème choseil faut répondre
aux gens qui s'inquiètent justement des
vages d'immigration qui ne vont cesser
en Occident sa ne serait-ce que par le
réchauffement climatique en alors vous
avez entiment raison je pense qu'il ne
faut pas mépriser les peurs de ceux qui
pensent que leur mode de vie nos modes
de vie sont
aujourd'hui bouleversés et qui
attribuent la responsabilité de ces
bouleversements aux migrations je pense
que c'est une erreur des attribués aux
migration mais il faut pas mépriser ces
ports là et je vais vous poser une
question dans les territoires où
aujourd'hui on vote RN et où la gare a
fermé la dernière classe de l'école a
fermé la dernière boulangerie a fermé la
maternité dans laquelle on avait
accouché on espérait que ces enfants
accouchent à fermé est-ce que les
Syriens sont responsables de la
fermeture de la gare est-ce que les
Maliens sont responsables du fait qu'il
y a pas de médecin mais mieux que ça non
seulement ils ne sont pas responsables
mais jeux vous dire Perm de la réouvrir
mais ça peut être un boulanger CDE qui
réouvre la boulangerie ça peut être
l'installation d'une famille qui permet
qu'une classe soit maintenue et donc une
école ne ferme pas ça peut être
l'existence d'une d'une d'une nouvelle
famille qui permet aussi ou de plusieurs
familles sur un territoire qu'une gare
ne ferme pas dans ces territoires on a
aussi la télé on regarde ce qui se
passe dans dans des collèges dans le
Nord où Dominique ça y est j'ai perdu
son Dominique Bernard a été assassiné ce
qui s'est passé à Paris au pond de
toolbac les gens associent ça aussi à
une forme d'immigration comment on
détricote ce discours bah nous Singa
mais l'ONG que je dirige mais on est
innombrables ser ça c'est que on on
collecte des preuves que ça marche
l'inclusion et euh et on peut isoler des
des des des drames des tragédies un acte
terroriste un fait divers un crime ça n'
lève rien au fait que dans partout en
France le lien la connexion le fait que
ça marche et que les gens euh euh se
débarrassent de leurs angoisses et de
leurs peur ou d'une partie d'entre elles
à partir du moment où on se connaît et
on vit ensemble donc la première chose
que je voudrais dire c'est que euh l'
inclusion ça fonctionne et d'ailleurs
j'ai en le dire simplement c'est que on
nous dit oui on est incapable
aujourd'hui d'accueillir bon il y a eu
100000 Ukrainiens en quelques mois
l'État a fait le travail avec les
associations dont les ONG comme la
mienne et les collectivités locales pas
un Ukrainien a dormi dehors pourquoi des
Afghans et des Maliens dorment dehors
parce qu'on n pas fait le choix de
mettre en œuvre les mêmes politiques
l'accès au travail à la formation et à
un toit donc on sa imigration
transitoire et mais il y a plein
d'autres pays en guerre l'Afghanistan
c'est un pays en
Guer on savait que la plupart des
personnes n'allaient pas rester bah il y
a beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui quand on
parle d'immigration donc je vous
rappelle qu'il a un ce qu'on appelle
c'est pas joli mais un solde migratoire
c'est qu'on tient pas compte du fait des
gens qui repartent c'est pareil aussi
pour des populations qui sont qui
viennent de beaucoup plus loin d'autres
pays en guerre ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que si on doute de notre de
notre savoir-faire en matière
d'inclusion on ne devrait pas parce
qu'on sait faire et au fond ce que
j'aimais vous dire et peut-être que ça
va en en bouger quelques-uns
euh ces migrations internationales elles
vont continuer et il y a euh aujourd'hui
on peut juste histoire de se faire
plaisir croire qu'en choisissant euh euh
des politiques qui disent on va tout
fermer ça va marcher ça ne marchera pas
pas plus qu'avec Trump pas plus qu'avec
bolsonaro pas plus qu'avec mélonie ou le
brexit ça ne marchera pas et ce que
j'observe c'est que la les extrêmes
aujourd'hui elles ne proposent
que qu'à se faire la guerre entre nous
et c'est d'ailleurs le propre de
l'extrême droite que de commencer par
faire la guerre à son propre peuple moi
ce que j'entends aujourd'hui venu des
médias d'extrême droite et des des
représentants d'extrême droite c'est
qu'il y aurait deux peuples en France
pour un seul territoire c'est terrifiant
parce que ça nous prépare aujourd'hui à
des formes de guerre civil et
méfiez-vous et méfions-nous nous sommes
quand même le peuple français qui a
proposé à travers sa constitution à
travers la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyens à travers son
projet de publque a proposé un projet
aux femmes et aux hommes indépendamment
de leur origine ethnique la République
n'est pas un projet ethnique et si on
commence à dire comme je l'entends à
l'extrême droite au rassemblement
national chez les partisans d'éc Zemmour
sur C news avec Monsieur boloret et
surtous les médias du groupe de Monsieur
bolloret que il y a aujourd'hui une
forme d'intolérance ethnique pour
d'autres groupes que celui qui serait
celui des Européens caucasiens blancs
chrétiens et cetera ça nous prépare des
c'est la question comment on évite la
montée de cette radicalité on a vu les
manifestations là depuis le meurtre de
Thomas qui euh qui qui essème un peu
partout en France comment on évite ça
bah euh d'abord on condamnant ce qui
s'appelle être une ratonade raciste en
condamnant évidemment le meurtre euh euh
d'un jeune homme dans une bagarre dans
un bal dont il semble que l'enquête qui
progresse montre qu'elle ne correspond
pas exactement à l'instrumentalisation
qui en a été faite par l'extrême droite
mais allez-vous me dire
les gens qui font ça qui exploitent ça
sont-ils respectables ceux qui
aujourd'hui au moindre fait d' hiiver
prennent le prénom la vie d'un jeune
homme qui est tombé assassiné pour en
faire leur rtandard pour aller euh pour
lancer des appels à la haine partout ces
gens-là sont-ils respectables mais
est-ce que ça illustre pas les deux
Frances face- à faceace dont parlait
Gérard Colomb non mais euh moi je crois
pas je pense que si on ériige ça comme
une réalité quand le quand tous les
jours on est capable de collecter des é
preuves du contraire oui on va finir par
euh faire en sorte que les groupes les
plus radicalisés s'affrontent et on ne
verra plus que ça ben moi je ne veux pas
regarder l'agenda des groupes
radicalisés je ne veux pas regarder les
les fantasmes terrifiants de Messieurs
pro et Zemour face à je ne sais qui
donner le l de de nos vies quotidiennes
de la vie politique il y a aujourd'hui
une France qui vit travaille se lève vit
avec comment dire dans l'interc
culturalité et elle vit bien elle
développe sa tolérance le niveau de
tolérance des Français augmente ils
disent à la fois qu'ils veulent moins de
migration mais en même temps que la
migration est une richesse il le
reconnaissent et et c'est intéressant
nous avec Singa on a fait un sondage il
y a peu de temps 65 % des Français
disent qu' a des conditions comparables
aux conditions de vie de ceux qui
viennent de loin ils migreraient
eux-mêmes ce qui veut dire que la
migration on la conçoit le cas échéant
pour soi et on la comprend et et en même
temps maintenant le défi collectif c'est
ça savoir comment on prépare des
sociétés inclusives et interculturelles
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
répondre à au méchant Derot un dernier
mot puisque sur ce sujet jeudi soir vous
participerez à un grand meeting de la
gauche pour lutter contre ce projet de
loi immigration il y aura Olivier fort
pour le Parti socialiste Yannick jado
pour les écologistes des communistes des
insoumis mais pas les proches de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est la nouvelle
Nupe oh là là vous me posez des coles là
non mais elle est bien il est bien alors
franchement que que que les partis de
gauche invitent des syndicalistes des
ONG qu' se rassemble sur une question
qui est de dire
euh il faut être inclusif interculturel
arrêtons de de de stigmatiser
l'immigration je trouve c'est c'est
vraiment une bonne nouvelle euh et et
mais qui est pas la ligne Mélenchon
c'est une bonne nouvelle
aussi moi je franchement je veux pas
rentrer là-dedans il y a quasiment tout
le monde donc moi je vais c'est toujours
pareil c'est soit on regarde le fait que
le verre est un petit peu est-ce que lui
participe à clivé puisque vous dites il
y a incontestablement un des acccords
stratégiques à gauche aujourd'hui et et
et ce désaccord stratégique il se noue
autour de d'une question assez simple
faut-il pour reconquérir le pouvoir
fracturer la société et la fracturer en
espérant se consolider un socle de dur
de de partisans ou faut-il proposer
aujourd'hui sur la question sociale sur
notamment un rassemblement qui nous
permette de faire face à la perspective
du rassemblement national moi je crois
plutôt à cette deuxième solution j'ai
jamais été un adepte de de cette
stratégie de la fracturation donc elle
vous paraît dangereuse cette stratégie
de la fracturation je point de vue
social non je je la crois euh je la
crois inefficace c'est le le et je pense
que inefficace politiquement ouis
inefficace politiquement et
électoralement mais vis-à-vis de la
société est-ce que ça inquite moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui euh euh il faut euh
je je comprends he le le le ce que ce
qui ce qui se passe mais je pense que
c'est il faut au contraire essayer de de
de de de créer des liens des passerelles
des ponts euh euh plutôt que de creuser
des tranch Jean Mélenchon est dangereux
aujourd'hui non non non attention je
veux dire moi il y a des je feris je je
partage pas plusieurs prises de position
qui sont les siennes mais euh le danger
dans ce pays aujourd'hui c'est l'extrême
droite hein le danger dans ce pays c'est
avir plusieurs dangersou mais moi je
considère que le danger majeur dans ce
pays c'est l'extrême droite avec un L
majuscule et un D majuscule et et et si
et c'est contre celui-là qu' faut
combattre merci merci beaucoup beno mon
merci d'avoir été notre invité
Christelle la Une de La Dépêche c'est
aussi Gabriel àal redoublement bac
brevet plan choc pour l'école c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup on
passe au club de territoires